so
welcome for the second part
um so jean jean and i will be
presenting the foundation of our ml
platform i
get your guide so my name is theodore
and i'm french working at get your guide
since
august 2021 as a data scientist
in the recommendation and relevance team
hey everybody uh my name is jim carlo
machado i'm from brazil
i'm in europe now for three years
working at gettro guide
and there as an engineer facing
uh solving problems around
recommendations
search and ranking basically
so in the next 25 minutes i will present
how we laid the
foundation of our ml platform at get
your guide
so to make to make it easier for data
scientists to
iterate through the cycle of first id
then coding then experiment
so if you have any question please write
it down in the chat
and we will answer them at the end
okay great uh so this is our agenda for
this presentation
so first jean will start with an
introduction about get your guide
then we will dive into the use cases
that we have in data science
in our company and jean will also
present
how we iterated on the deployment of our
models and their limitations
next we will have uh represent the
foundation of our platform uh in the
first part we'll explain how we lev how
we leverage mlfo
ml flow sorry to manage our models and
then
in second part john will explain how we
use the templating to bootstrap our
project
with a good practices and we'll conclude
with some final words and open for
questions
yes so to talk about our machine
learning platform
uh in get your guide first we have to uh
introduce get your guide i guess
for european ideals like this uh it's
you probably know the company but in
case you don't know
so get your guide is building one of the
biggest marketplaces for travel
experiences
uh we are connecting millions of
customers over
our catalog of more than 40 000
experiences worldwide
uh to summarize our mission is to give
access to the world for incredible
experiences
and to get more concrete
about what that means is so
if you want for instance to skydive on
the sugarloaf in rio
or uh you want to see the sunset of new
york city
from the top of the empire state
building
or explore food markets on hong kong
at your guide is a place to uh
to find this kind of activities and it's
just some few clicks away
of you um as you might guess the travel
sector was pretty much hit
by the pandemic
so we took this time as our opportunity
to uh
invest heavily on our tag foundations
um yeah to be ready for the market
rebound
and the machine learning platform is
part of this investment
[Music]
so back to me so now that you have a
kind of
an idea of what the company is doing i
will tell you more about
how we are using ml at get your guide so
actually
our data sense team started five years
ago
and uh and during this time until today
the amount of projects
that we own grew and so we use machine
learning
in different areas so for example we
use them to uh to rank the activities
with couples to
uh to show on the top the most relevant
from our inventory
and we show them on the different
landing pages and also the search result
result pages and see you can have an
example here
you can also just go get your guide and
we'll find
also our uh the the
website uh we also use machine learning
to recommend personalized activities to
our customers with panels that we
distribute also on the
on the website and on the app
we also uh use machine learning to help
the tourists to discover destination
and first the best activities on get
your guide
with paid search the most famous
one with google and
also we also use ml for domain
forecasting
to predict uh uh
to try to predict what will be the
demands of our pre-buy tickets and also
simply for planning
we also use ml for automatically
labeling our inventory
of activities so in total we have
currently more than 20 projects that we
need to currently maintain
uh and which is distributed among two
teams and we also have
uh some models that are in other teams
and we also need to
some from time to time maintain
and so as you can see we start to reach
our critical size
and uh so for that to try to stay
aligned between the different teams
and the different uh project
we agree on a set of principles that we
all follow
uh and we cannot split them in
kind of six pillars so the first one
will be about the strategy so how do we
prioritize the work
and so for example we favor business
value of a state-of-the-art models
the workflow how do we plan our work so
we
we incorporate the data to inform our
planning dynamically
the third one will be about the model
how we build our model
so we value small iteration of existing
model
and finally also the performance is only
proven online with a b test
which is very important for us
then the first one is about qa how do we
assure the quality of model so
if we are building we we want to build
solid and reasonable deployment
uh then we have the entering principle
uh
how do we build basically how do we
build our infrastructure and we want to
make sure
that our work is reproducible and also
modular
and finally the stakeholder engagement
how do we engage with our partner
and we want to promote and educate our
partners across the company
about the data product mindset so
in a retrospective uh we showed that for
two of those uh oh sorry
yeah two uh for two of this dimension
especially
the so the qa and the injuring we
uh we're not at standard
so if you are building a model maybe
just for research and you are the only
one using it
it might not be a big deal if you have a
broken model uh
for some days but for us it's quite
critical because if one of our model is
done
then it will affect the website and
ultimately our customers
and that means we are losing potential
revenue and
this can go really quick fast so in the
magnitude of thousands of euros for
every hours our model are done
so we agree that we need to improve this
dimension
and this is what this
platform is about so now jean will
explain a bit more
about the different approach that we
have to develop and deploy our models
so as you said we've been doing machine
learning for
around now five years and uh until
2019 around we've been using this
approach
of notebooks first and to
go to production and basically notebooks
are great we
indispensable for us they are widely
used by
ml practitioners they have a very
low uh entry uh point for
people you don't have to install a
system in your machine to start doing
machine learning you can just open a tab
in your browser
they are great to start new projects
prototype ideas
and also they have amazing visualization
for you know
tech people so they are great and
very necessary for doing data science
but uh
they have also some features that are
not
very suitable for going to production
for instance you can
most notebook solutions you don't have
uh
proper version control it's also not the
best platform
to do reuse um
and also it's not the right place to do
tests you don't have
uh uh yeah the infrastructure in place
to do that
notebooks then uh are very easy to break
in summary uh
what if you are going to production with
a notebook running
your system and you open that notebook
and accidentally type something
i'm very good at typing stuff from
notebook cells
and that's very easy to break your c
your system uh
and in our case breaker systems really
means like stop
ranking relevant products for when the
user searches
or not or showing noise in our
recommendations
or even like paying a lot of money to
google to betting the wrong that
so there's clear side effects that uh
for us
uh not uh make it a not good decision to
go in that direction
so and also they are uh so they
actually go into production with
notebooks is not uh aligned with our
principles we cannot also
build increments of code and maintain it
for a long term
like with teams maintaining it rather
than individuals as you said if you are
just one person
working on a research the constraints
are very different
so to be truthful to our principles we
saw that we needed an improvement
next slide so the second approach
we took towards improving this
system was this was made like from 2019
2020
um we ported our code to github
and uh that
then removing the uh
the necessity to uh run notebooks in
production
the the workflow looks more or less like
this you
have some working piece of code in a
notebook then import it to a library
uh but still then there is a question on
how you deploy it and we opted for the
simplest at first to be incremental
so um we build it as a python library
and basically do a manual deploy to our
s3 buckets
that can run stand in our in production
infrastructure
[Music]
yes but this approach also has its
limitations
uh when you start from a github entity
project
you have like zero uh
out of the box automation uh for
your quality the quality aspects of your
project
uh and um that makes also
means that the different projects will
have different
ways of uh automating and they will look
very different people will find
different diversion solutions as
hard to avoid people in such a different
set of engineering practices
so given that everything also starts
from the zero ground
we most of the solutions ended up doing
manual deployment and also
a new deployment for the bucket
you can see how that can breaks where it
can break very fast
uh just by doing enough times uh manual
deployment
you gonna break it eventually uh and uh
what's not only once that happened we
were building a testing model and uh
somehow wrote in the production uh
location so you broke the system this
way
um yeah that's two dimensions or
problems with this approach the third is
that we don't have
actually tracking we are also of our
parameters we are in the dark
for in to know uh which parameters
uh the data scientists use to tune the
model
all the learnings that happen uh that
led to the model to be
what it is you if you don't have that
tracked
other people joining your project might
have to
relearn these things and uh
yeah that just makes it much more
expensive and hard to collaborate
so all all these uh problems led us to
to the need of thing uh to the
conclusion that we need to think on
machine learning more realistically in
our
thus the need of a machine learning
platform
next and so now i will present
uh more about the platform and so what
we built so far
so we'll break it down in two in two
parts so first i will talk a bit more
about
how we make sure that uh uh
that we are making machine learning
reproducible
and so for that um we can say that
actually if in machine learning if you
just have the code
usually you cannot go that far uh you
can it's bad
but if you have the code and the data
it's already better because at least you
can try to reproduce
but what you expect is have the code
the data and also the executables so
with that you are kind of
understand uh what are the libraries
that are needed the version
of them and so this is a good way to
make it repositionable finally
what you what you should have as a gold
standard and what which will aim for
sort of the code the data the executable
uh and also the logs
uh so with that you are able to iterate
faster because
if something is broken between two
iteration uh then you just need to
compile the
compare the the the the version
uh between the two to be able to fix it
quickly uh the end of the
uh faster also because you have
everything that you need to
understand what happened previously and
also
if you want uh for the scientific method
approach
this is the right way to improve our
model to be able to reproduce each steps
that
led to this point and so
uh to help us with that we are use we
use
a new tool and would like to introduce
you to
mlflow so we leverage ml flow
which is an open source software and
the goal of this software project is to
have a kind of platform not limited to
view framework
uh or also company infrastructure and
these
tools uh is really useful for us in uh
in two areas so first it allows to log
the metrics the parameter
and also the output parameter output
model that uh
we train and this is with the the
tracking uh
module from mlpro and also
uh we are able to see the different
we can have an overview of all the model
that we are currently using in
production
and so for that they have the model
registry uh
concepts with ml flow and so with this
we are able to make it reproducible
because we
with that we have the conversion that we
that we are using for that training
because uh with the git hash we can log
them in mr flow
we have the data that we that we store
and we log the path to make sure that we
know where it's coming from
we have the executable which is the
docker image that we also
is but it's large with an overflow and
finally we have all the logs that are
linked to the nfl and also
pushed uh to a in a nice ui
and i will show you how it looks like on
the on the ui so
for the tracking so all the experiments
this is an example
of an experiment so a set of runs that
we have
that you can have and so here you have
in one dashboard all the runs that you
did
and you can see the different parameters
that were used the different metrics
um and you can also order them by
parameters filters etc and you see
uh when it was started uh what
who was the user etc etc uh
so and the second one is about the ml
flow model registry
so this is the dashboard where we see
all the model that we have in production
and also you have a stage for each of
them so we know if they are in staging
production
or archived and uh by also
digging into that we can see like the
different version from when to when they
were in which stage
uh who changed them from stages
and also go back to the tool to the
training and
see that the the metric that were used
the parameters
uh and the logs
okay and just to give you a small
example
like how it looks in the code uh it's
actually fairly simple
so you just import mlflow and then you
can just
let me put the pointer uh you just with
enough load start run and if you want to
log the parameters
you just log a parameter if you want to
log a metrics etc
and once you have a model that you have
that you want to fit
then you can log the mobile by saying
with a model
when you want to have it saved and if
you want to register a model to have it
in the model history you just
say how you want to have it there so a
very
very interesting tool
talk now about the second part of the
puzzle so we see
reproducibility as key for a platform
but to have it and also being able to
apply to production reliably we have to
increase the amount of automation we
have on our systems
and a concept that summarizes this
automation concern is
mlops uh which was originally
derived as a derivation of devops which
were
a practice of summarizes machine
learning operations
uh more specific to machine learning
rather than
uh devops and uh
but a central tenet of this ops movement
uh is that every change we make in our
code base
uh in the master branch is ready to go
to production it's like a production
valid
change uh that improved a lot the
software engineering practices and we
believe that it can improve also our
machine learning practices
so uh not only every change
should be able to go to production it
should
go to production automatically which
uh requires and to do that it requires
some automation in place
not to start from zero with the github
repository
to solve that problem we came up with a
solution of a template
that i will explain you next
so in get your guide we have internal
tooling that is used to
uh speed up the development process
like if you want to set up a service or
someone you can use this
tool and uh it's basically
contains uh a templating on steroids
functionality which allowed us to create
our own
machine learning service template
and this template then it does
it sets up a skeleton for our machine
learning uh project
but uh also creates the github
repository
creates the aws infrastructure necessary
to run
this model and integrates with
ml flow and it also
adds ci cd so
[Music]
cicd is basically the practice that
allows us to go to production
automatically while making
our systems making sure that our systems
are working and we'll explain you them
in the next slide it's in details
sorry yeah so
uh that's every
change we do in our uh github
repo that contains a model will then
pass
using our cicd pipeline it will pass
through a series
of checks and if all these checks are uh
positive they will end up in production
basically so
our first series of checks are units
tests we set
up some by default but uh the data
scientist then uh
as is desirable that he continues
building
new tests and uh we do also
style checks type system checks with my
pi
and security checks to see for instance
if you are using uh out state version of
a dependency
and once all of those checks are done we
trigger automatic training
that if also succeeds we then go do
automatic deployment
in the next step we have a visualization
of this process
so all starts with a notebook the data
scientists do the exploration
and we reach a point where we say hey
this goes
this is a serious project let's leave it
move it to production so at that point
the data scientist basically bootstraps
a new service
it creates all the infrastructure and at
every change
we trigger an automatic deploy that
if succeeds uh trains
our model and saves it into ml flow and
from ml flow
then we are ready to distribute to many
other sources and what flow
makes it uh is the ml4 registry is the
place where our mother resides and can
go to production
so so some to conclude
uh so as we grew uh
our data sentence we need to refine our
our process and to make it more
sophisticated
so to do that we integrated good soft
uh good software engineering practices
and we also
added some twists to be able to adapt to
machine learning
especially with mr flow and this
automatic training
and with that we can help our data
scientists to
first build faster by focusing on the
model
and the data and not on the
infrastructure and setting things up so
instead of needed one or two a few days
to be able to
uh to start a new project then in 10
minutes your
you have it ready and set up we
are we are able to deploy safer with
automated test
and the ci uh every time and also we
have
auto automatic documentation uh
of the experiments that we are doing uh
thanks to mlflow
and regarding the next steps for the
platform
right now the teams are in the process
of supporting the projects we have to
the template
and at the same time we are looking into
real-time predictions
and uh that's that's a feature desirable
for
uh real-time personalization so we
wanted to really react
for the latest interactions of the
customers in the website
and the platform is just uh yet the
right place to uh iterate on that
concept
we are also uh we already foresee the
need of a feature star so
uh as our mo we add more and more models
we wanted to reuse the features
that they are composed of and uh so we
need a place to
set them all and be able to retrieve
them
and uh yeah we are continuously looking
into monitoring in our systems
uh it's very easy for the models
to drift in production and uh yeah
that's
something we will be continuously
investing on
uh yeah the last slide uh
this basically completes our
presentation uh
if this kind of work also sounds
interesting to you
uh you must not i
we are hiring and uh the link is just in
this light you can
access it and now we are open to go
through
the questions
okay thank you very much uh so one of
the questions that was
asked by matalina was uh
are you running ammo flow on data bricks
with a smiley face yeah and then
uh yeah do you want to say something
yeah i just wanted to say maybe
for the people who do not know uh
databricks is kind of
a data platform provider and which also
provide
a way to have a centralized notebook
which run on cluster and be able to
use spark and
and also they also propose a
management flow
a small remark by abdu
uh would be nice to have a whole
workflow summary
uh from hypothesis idea to fully
automated
reproduction is that a possibility or
actually yeah we have a
uh we wrote a blog post uh which we
should go live
in the next month so
and we will go through exactly this
whole process of
uh going from hypothesis to id and then
uh going to production with that yeah
that's true that's our question
um another question by
i'm not exactly uh what he's referring
to but why have you made your
own uh there are aws
sagemaker and azure ml
i mean you know
yeah we are picking the pieces from many
open source projects uh
and actually uh we have to
already uh take into account our legacy
or the way that we do things databricks
is at
the core of our operations so uh and
also it's just a natural
uh follow-up from that and we still can
leverage sagemaker to go to production
that's actually one of the tools for
our real-time inference that we are
analyzing
but uh yeah so we are for sure not
inventing everything at home okay so we
yeah sure yeah we we do not try to
reinvent the wheel and
actually we are not building our own we
are not
assembling our own so we are taking the
parts of the different things so
so another question by abdul um what do
you mean by automatic training
automl or why not use some ml
ops framework but then you just
basically mentioned i think
your ml ops right
i think the question basically answered
itself
or do you want to comment on this so we
are not using automl but what we made by
automatic training is when you have
uh when you push something into the
github repository
it will automatically run the test
and if the test path and uh you are also
pushing to master so we don't want to
so when we want to have a new basically
model
by pushing a new feature to master then
it will automatically
that's what i mean automatically it will
start trigger a training
on the whole data set so
a very elaborate chrome job
um so another question um
uh are you using something like cookie
cutter uh
for templating probably that wouldn't be
enough
for the thing you achieve or
uh so cookie got is a really good
example uh so we are not choosing cucuta
we are using ginger
uh behind the scene which is kind of the
same the same
thing but uh why we have what we have
with geek that actually
is more than that because it's
also basically already setting up the
infrastructure so we are
connecting within our flow we are
connecting with the databricks we have
the
secrets managed we create the ecr so all
this thing
is already pushed together directly
so you don't have to do this you just
have to run kick that foot strap
so yes exactly cookie cutter will not be
enough
so uh i don't see any more questions and
i don't have any questions either um
and i didn't see any questions on
youtube youtube was
sort of quiet this time oh there is
another
question can you speak a bit about any
challenges
you have faced with understanding
utilization of the
deployed models and how you've addressed
them
another do you understand what is meant
i think the challenges in understanding
the utilization of deployment
right so i'm not sure
can you can you restrain
[Music]
one thing to say is one big challenge is
to have the right
data in place so uh
we are also like at this point uh
putting uh on hold all or uh
iterations on some specific models of
recommendations because we
still don't have the data to see if our
changes
are uh being uh affecting our
our pipeline in uh correct way so uh
the teams and the teams that own the the
these events and sending this data
around
are distributed so there are many social
challenges around
uh just uh monitoring your
your model and see if that's working in
the right direction i'm not sure if that
exactly answer your question
uh maybe you have another take on it
yeah so if you've seen zombie model uh
accumulating over time uh so actually we
have the
we we have like quite event driven so we
know the number of requests that
have been sent and so each time we have
a new request that we know
we are able to to measure how
requested our server our models are
so they are not getting zombies
definitely they are
heavily used but
what is sometimes challenging is
uh moving from one model to the next
with a new api or thing like that
because
getting all the consumer of our models
to adapt
to the new model which might need new
parameters i think that that
is what is uh challenging because each
team have its own priorities and things
like that
but that's uh yeah
it's not specific to ml any kind of
micro service architecture
kind of have these challenges i believe
okay there are a bunch of new questions
uh
do you see them yeah uh so after
what framework monitoring do you use for
a b testing
uh so not us
but get your guy build its own
framework for a b testing um where we
are basically
able to flip the coins uh to be able to
test
new features and it's used heavily by uh
by a lot of teams actually from design
to machine learning
uh to also back ends um
and for the monitoring uh maybe jean you
can answer that
better i wasn't sure if it's monitoring
for ap testing specific or monitoring
general but there are two for
keeper t uh yeah keep an eye on our
systems
is data talk domain one there's a lot of
there's other
tools like for monitoring or however
events behave
uh but uh laserdog is the more
the biggest one and question
from is there any concept of ownership
of particle
uh sorry it's a concept of ownership of
particular models
uh in your platform extending on create
so yes the models are owned by teams
basically
and they are responsible to um
to keep them running and keep them
healthy basically
um and there are mission teams like for
instance our team is recommendations and
relevance
as another team taking care of our
ads and so they're kind of clustered
around domains and
the team owned them basically